[Musica]
[Applauso]
tra i problemi che adesso interessano la
nostra società
uno dei più importanti è quello di
cercare di avere sempre delle attività
ecosostenibili ed ecocompatibili e la
nostra sfida o la sfida delle globale è
quella di cercare di passare dalla
economia verde green economy a quella
economia blu in che cosa consiste questo
passaggio il passaggio consiste sul
fatto che l'economia verde e un'economia
che decisamente è positiva ma ha un
grosso problema
costa molto mentre l'economia blu che
quella che si dovrebbe cercare di
attivare nel più breve tempo possibile è
quella che a zero impatto e zero consumo
è quello che cerca cioè di avere il
tutto utilizzando l'energia della terra
allora questo tipo di energia
ovviamente questo tipo di attività deve
essere fatta anche considerando le
risorse terrestri ma soprattutto le
risorse marine ed è quello che il nostro
dipartimento comunque nelle nostre
università i nostri istituti di ricerca
sa di cercano di fare ora che cosa si fa
nel particolare nel particolare noi si è
fatto delle campagne e thalasso grafiche
delle campagne di monitoraggio che sono
iniziate più o meno nel 1984
sono tuttora in corso e hanno
evidenziato lo stato delle risorse dei
mari sardi e dei mari italiani al
mediterraneo in generale ma per avere
idea una maggior per avere idea di come
sono le risorse
prendiamo per esempio alcune pescate che
sono state fatte abbattimenti che
diverse le campagne di pesca che sono
state effettuate sono state effettuate
fra i 10 e 1000 metri di profondità le
pescate fatte intorno ai 600 metri
come si può vedere da queste diapositiva
sono delle pescate che dove
il prodotto commerciale e vicino all 80
per cento quindi la maggior parte delle
risorse che vengono pescate sono
commercializzate quindi diciamo che lo
spreco di proteine nobili è
relativamente basso ma se ci si sposta
se si va in profondità minori intorno ai
400 metri si vede che la la proporzione
si cambia ed è esattamente il contrario
cioè fra il 20 al 30 per cento viene
commercializzato e il resto avviene
perso normalmente veniva ributtato in
mare adesso con la nuove disposizioni
ministeriali dovrebbero essere
recuperate e cercate e convertite in
mangimistica e se trattandosi ovviamente
sempre di proteine nobili dame ancora se
si va ancora a livelli più bassi cioè
entrando intorno verso i 200 metri
allora sia veramente se assiste
veramente ad uno spreco di risorse su
sono delle pescate che sono intorno ai
1000 kg di prodotto il prodotto
commerciale si aggira intorno ai 10 20
figli non di più quindi è evidente che
questo è uno spreco ma a questo si
assume si aggiunge anche il fatto che
molte specie che sono interessantissime
per altre regioni d'italia non essendo
non avendo mercato nella nostra isola
queste sono delle risorse perse questo
per esempio questa è una pescata di
cicerelli che farebbe la gioia e la
richiesta dei pescatori liguri
queste sono liberi di pesce sciabola che
farebbe la ricchezza dei pescatori
siciliani
bene allora che cos'è che si è cercato
di fare senza caso di fare di cercato di
fare si è fatto è messa a punto una
tecnica che consente di pescare
limitare molto le beckett cioè le
catture accessori in particolari che
cosa consiste consiste su questo tipo di
pesca consiste nel fatto di creare un
cono d'ombra e poi un cono d'ombra e
delle vibrazioni in che cosa consiste la
trezzano attrezzo non è altro che sono
due funi parallele che vengono trainati
dai due da due pescherecci o da due
imbarcazioni queste funi hanno una
distanza tra loro di circa un metro un
metro e mezzo dove sono legati a queste
foni sono legati delle buste di plastica
ovviamente biodegradabili oppure degli
stracci sempre biodegradabili questo
mentre ci sono trainati ad una velocità
più o meno di un video miglia mezzo
l'ora creano delle vibrazioni e creano
un cono d'ombra questo le vibrazioni
insieme al cono d'ombra hanno il potere
potere di aggregare le forme iti che i
pesci di condurli insieme di condurli
tutti insieme come se fosse un gregge
questo che cosa consente consente di
utilizzare una certa frequenza d'onda di
utilizzare un certo periodo di
utilizzare questi sistemi di cattura
finali che consentiranno di avere delle
pesche mono specifiche di pesche il
prodotto di un prodotto di di dimensioni
volute e quindi sicuramente a con basso
impatto ambientale
allora l'individuazione di un sistema di
pesca che consenta di ridurre l'impatto
fisico sul substrato che consenta di
ridurre di ridurre le catture accessorie
di ridurre lo spreco è un qualcosa che
viene al che viene auspicato sia dei
nostri ministeri che dalla comunità
europea
ora potrebbe sorgere la domanda ma come
mai questo tipo di pesca non è attivate
non viene non viene effettuato
ma non viene effettuato semplicemente
perché per effettuare questo tipo di
pesca occorre essere degli specialisti
ma ha anche un altro un lato con dato
negativo
il lato negativo è che ha un grosso
potere di cattura bilità cioè
normalmente i sistemi di pesca catturano
03 04 per 10 mentre questo sistema si
avvicina al 100 per cento quindi dove
passa questo sistema di pesca rimane ben
poco e quindi deve essere in qualche
modo ripetuto non ripetuto nel tempo o
al tempo dovuto con grande un grande
intervalli per dare possibilità allo
stop di ricostituirsi però questo tipo
di attività è un'attività che in qualche
modo vede gli operatori della pesca
quindi i pescatori come collaboratori
dei tecnici ma lo scopo uno scopo del
nostro ateneo del nostro torneo è quello
di far sì che come si suol dire che
l'università scende dalla cattedra e si
misuri con le realtà locali con le
realtà sociali con il mondo con le
categorie una delle nostre iniziative è
stata quella di fare dei ripopolamenti
attivi di aragosta sulla ragosta
come sapete la ragosta e un crostaceo
che ha grande interesse economico che è
molto ricercato e di conseguenza è stato
nel tempo sovra pescato ora per cercare
di rimettere il sistema o in ordine lo
stop far sì che si possa avere una
continuità di pescato nel tempo si è
pensato di collaborare con gli operatori
cioè fa sì che anche i pescatori siano
dei co autori della ricerca
quindi sono state identificate delle
aree
idonei delle aree di pesca dove sono
state immesse delle aragoste piccole per
far sì che sono stati messi delle
regaste piccole in modo che potessero
crescere nel tempo e potessero in
qualche modo essere gestita dai
pescatori la realtà qual è la cosa che
cosa è successo che i pescatori essendo
stati coinvolti ed essendosi anche lo s
e sentendosi dei primi attori hanno in
qualche modo custodito l'attività
custodito l'area è vitato la pesca
abusiva e soprattutto hanno ridotto di
molto il mercato nero quindi il mercato
nero degli agosti vendute sotto taglia
quelle che normalmente vengono vendute
alla ristorazione e queste remote sono
stati immesse in questi in queste aree
nel tempo con il successo che nel giro
di 7 8 anni la biomassa quindi le
risorse sono cresciute di oltre il 500
per cento ma non soltanto perderà ghosts
e anche per i pesci che abitavano ricchi
tutti i pesci liti o fauna che in
qualche modo collegate abbinata alle
aragoste
successivamente questa era volte questi
queste aree sono state in qualche modo
gestite sempre dai pescatori e
conservate
visto il successo fisso il primo
successo gli stessi operatori hanno
desiderato hanno chiesto alla regione
sardegna che venissero istituite altre
aree di fatto ne sono state istituite
altre 14 ma a livello nazionale e
internazionale
e successo che questo tipo di gestione
questo tipo di gestione ha avuto il
consenso di tutte le marinerie del
mediterraneo ma soprattutto quelle della
comunità europea della stessa comunità
europea a auspica che questo tipo di
iniziative che viene fatta dal pescatore
della sardegna sia in qualche modo
emulata copiata
assimilata da altre dalle altre
marinerie questa diciamo che in realtà è
quella è la ricerca e sono le attività
che in qualche modo hanno un ora hanno
un riscontro immediato però se se
guardiamo i nostri mari
vediamo che i nostri mali hanno una
elevata biodiversità e l'isola e la
sardegna è riconosciuta perché è l'isola
dei cosiddetti centenari quindi esistono
delle zone della sardegna dove il numero
dei centenari e decisamente in
proporzione superiore a quelle di altre
regioni italiane e anche di altre
regioni europee ma nel contempo nel mare
sono state trovate le foreste ma le
foreste non centenarie ma mille na
millenarie delle delle datazioni che
abbiamo fatto su queste piante su questi
coralli hanno dimostrato che corali di
circa 4 centimetri di diametro anno
oltre 1900 anni ma le colonie che sono
state in qualche motorino inoltre nel
substrato hanno uno spessore di 8
centimetri quindi è logico pensare che
se 4 cm anno circa duemila anni o 3
centimetri possono possono superare
moltissimo quindi la nostra isola non è
più un'isola di centenari o non era
soltanto un isola di centenari ma
dobbiamo considerarla anche un'isola di
millenari tutto questo che cosa che cosa
apposta ma port harcourt sicuramente a
fare alcune considerazioni
se noi abbiamo questo male se noi
abbiamo queste biodiversità
sicuramente lo dobbiamo anche agli
operatori che hanno saputo rispettare le
nostre ricchezze ma l'altra questione
che deve essere assolutamente prese in
considerazione il fatto che la sardegna
è al centro del mediterraneo centro
occidentale
quindi è al centro quindi equidistante
sia dal nord africa che dal resto del
europa continentale quindi in qualche
modo deve essere il trait d'union che
può che può e deve far sì che le
università ed istituti di ricerca che
resistono sia in sardegna sia nel nord
africa e parlo dell'algeria della
tunisia e dal marocco che hanno grandi
tradizioni marinare a livello di ricerca
possano in qualche modo ed ebbero in
qualche modo o debbano necessariamente
collaborare in un sistema che ci sia un
interscambio sia prima inizialmente come
ricercatori poi successivamente come
tipo di attività o con le attività che
sono state in qualche modo di illustrate
prima in modo da ampliare il sistema è
far sì che ci sia uno scambio ma non sia
uno scambio operativo fra le realtà sia
scientifiche che sia quelle che scheda
volano nel territorio
[Musica]